now we're going to continue our coverage
here with vanessa who heard from one
woman
who says she fell victim to fraud
vanessa
yeah thanks joe while many nevadans are
waiting for those unemployment dollars
thieves and fraudsters are stealing the
money on top of that
it's difficult to report the issue and
get results
it took me it took me two and a half
months to get my back unemployment
like many nevadans lori ballentine
waited for unemployment dollars and then
once she began receiving the money
another hurdle when tuesday came i
get my money i checked my account
information
and somebody had changed my bank account
information and my email address
later i found out they also changed my
place of birth valentine provided this
screenshot showing the money was sent to
metropolitan commercial bank in new york
851.25 she says she reached out to the
department of employment training and
rehabilitation or dieter
and she received this email stating
somebody will be in touch
more than a month ago and i still
haven't heard anything
and i've sent like 45 emails i've called
at 225 times
and can't get anybody for now more than
850 dollars
ballentine was relying on appears to
have been
stolen and it can't have just happened
to me she is another nevadan
disappointed with deter and a broken
unemployment system
i think that they weren't prepared by
the overwhelming number of people that
would be
applying
laurie valentine says she's not sure how
someone gained access to her account but
she believes she figured out
how they changed the bank info and she
says it looks
pretty simple i reached out to dieter
and a spokeswoman tells me she put it on
the list to hopefully
be addressed tomorrow i also reached out
to the bank in new york where that money
was transferred
and did not receive a response reporting
live vanessa murphy
8 news now